في اخبارنا الاخرى بدا الناخبون في
باكستان الادلاء باصواتهم لاختيار
105 عضو في البرلمان الفيدرالي بالعاصمه
اسلام اباد والبرلمانات المحليه في
الاقاليم الاربعه ويحق لاكثر من 128 مليون
ناخب المشاركه في الانتخابات البرلمانيه
العامه الثانيه من نوعها في تاريخ باكستان
وسيشكل الحزب الذي يحصل على تاييد ثلثي
النواب الحكومه المقبله وافاد مراسلنا
بمقتل عنصر امن في مقاطعه تنك باقليم خيبر
بعد دقائق من فتح صناديق
الاقتراع المزيد معنا من اسلام اباد الان
مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد الرحمن مطر عبد
الرحمن نرحب بك ضعنا في اجواء هذه
الانتخابات
اي فيان الانتخابات بدات قبل نحو ساعتين
من الان الاقتراع متواصل في عشرات الالاف
من مراكز الاقتراع في عموم باكستان
الاقتراع سيستمر حتى الساعه الثالثه بعد
ظهر اليوم بتوقيت مكه المكرمه وخلال هذه
الساعات التسعه بالتاكيد سيستطيع كل من
يريد المشاركه في هذه الانتخابات الادلاء
بصوته لا سما وان لجنه الانتخابات كانت قد
خصصت اكثر من مليون ونصف ايه موظف ايه
يعمل لديها للاشراف والمساهمه والمساعده
في هذه العمليه الانتخابيه التي تمتد على
ساعات نهار هذا اليوم لكن بالتاكيد هناك
الكثير من التحديات الامنيه والملقا على
عاتق اكثر من
277000 من جنود الجيش وعناصر الامن ورجال
الشرطه ايضا المنتشرين في عشرات الالاف من
مراكز الاقتراع الحكومه الباكستانيه كانت
قد اعلنت ان
17500 من مراكز الاقتراع تقع في مناطق
حساسه جدا من الناحيه الامنيه وهناك
بالفعل استعدادات كبيره من جانب قوات
الامن لضمان سير هذه العمليه بسلاسه وعدم
او السيطره على اي وضع امني قد يشوب هذه
العمليه الانتخابيه ايضا تم اغلاق
الانترنت وقطع الاتصالات في معظم ارجاء
البلاد ايضا ضمن الجهود والاجراءات
المبذوله حقيقه سيطره على الوضع الامني
بشكل عام وكي تتم العمليه الانتخابيه
بسلاسه مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد الرحمن مطر
من اسباد شكرا
لك